[Musique]
nous sommes le 9 février 2010 est
bienvenue pour cette nouvelle édition du
7 8 et les inviter à l'actualité avec et
celles et ceux qui en sont les acteurs
est aujourd'hui vous entendrez didier
guillemot c'est le président de
l'université de versailles saint quentin
en yvelines il reviendra sur les
perspectives pour 2010 est pour son
établissement
nous évoquerons aussi ensemble paris à
saclay alors que la cour des comptes
évoque un projet mal préparée et mal
pilotée dans son dernier rapport
et puis michel murr et c'est la
directrice du centre de formation aux
métiers du btp à trappes est également
invité pour évoquer les évolutions de la
profession les métiers qui sont
actuellement porteur et les formations
qui sont dispensés dans son centre le
secteur du btp qui semble connaître
aujourd'hui un regain d'activité bonsoir
michel murray dans un instant nous
parlons donc de vos formations dans
votre centre de formation à trappes à
saint quentin en yvelines et bonsoir des
animaux on va commencer tout de suite
sans vouloir vous vous énervez dès les
premières questions mais par ce rapport
annuel dans tout cas de la cour des
comptes qui constate que l'état s'est
lancé dans un projet ambitieux celui de
la construction d'une grande université
salle de paris saclay sans avoir
préalablement défini clairement les
moyens de le réaliser l'université de
versailles saint quentin en yvelines est
un acteur essentiel de cette université
de paris saclay on va détailler un petit
peu ce rapport quand même assez
brièvement mais malgré tout ses
premières conclusions vous en pensez
quoi
tout d'abord bonsoir d'invités
l'université ce soir j'en pense qu'il
n'y a rien de très original et très
nouveau dans le rapport c'est à dire que
le projet paris saclay est un projet
comme vous l'avez souligné extrêmement
ambitieux qu'on ne fait pas le monde en
un jour
vous l'imaginez et que évidemment et
qu'il y a des difficultés que les choses
il faut poser une pierre de pierre
frontières le rapport souligne un
certain nombre de choses concernant les
engagements financiers ou les
investissements financiers de l'état
mais c'est pas neuf
maintenant le pilotage ce sur des
dynamiques politiques
donc je pense qu'il n'y a pas grand
chose de surprenant dans ce rapport
l'idée de ce projet je le rappelle c'est
de concentrer sur le plateau de saclay
en essonne et ses environs de ses
environs immédiats des organismes
publics puissants des centres privés de
recherche une grande université de
recherche si internationalement reconnue
et puis de grandes écoles parmi les plus
prestigieuses dans les différents points
qui sont pointées par la cour des
comptes justement ce sont des
divergences entre universités donc de
logement étudiant de 30 de transport
aussi et puis ce rapport préconise que
l'état désigne un responsable
interministériel du projet paris saclay
alors je ne vais pas faire de
commentaire sur le rapport de la cour
des comptes et le délégué
interministériel tel qu'il est proposé
vous savez qu'à différents dimensionnant
projet saclay il ya une dimension
universitaire c'est de celle là dont je
vais parler pas ton de l'aménagement du
territoire ce que je veux souligner
c'est vous mentionnez le plateau mais
l'université paris saclay c'est aussi le
département des yvelines et le
territoire des yvelines
là où est implanté un certain en
yvelines versailles et sur saint quentin
en yvelines forcément et ça c'est
particulièrement important je le
rappelle quand je siège dans le comité
les membres une joute de l'université
paris saclay cette question de la
territorialité des formations
que nous avons dans notre université et
la manière dont des laboratoires de
recherche de l'excellence et des
formations des laboratoires de recherche
et de la nécessité de ce que paris
saclay et bien soutiennent le
développement territorial de nos
formations et de notre université
juste pour conclure sur ce point sur ce
rapport quand l'état préconise un
responsable interministériel pour le
projet aussi pour piloter
du côté de l'université ce serait une
bonne chose pour notre référence à un
référendum là je ne suis pas
complètement certain je pense que les
choses avancent
effectivement pas si rapidement que ça
va mais elle avance aussi avec plusieurs
partenaires un plus de dix-huit presque
20 je pense que le pilotage est bien et
plutôt pas si malmené que ça et on va
voir dans les mois qui viennent la
manière dont le jury international de
vie d'axa en l'occurrence et bien reçoit
les propositions qui seront faites en ce
qui vous concerne vous venez de tenir
votre première cérémonie de voeux en
tant que président de l'université de
versailles saint quentin en yvelines ce
que vous êtes en un président serein
alors j'y suis pour 2017 je suis serein
ambitieux écouter oui je le suis mais on
verra à la fin de l'année 2017 si j'ai
eu raison de l'être
je pense qu'il ya un ya un bilan on peut
faire sur 2016 avec des choses quand
même significatif qui sont survenus je
veux simplement la maison des étudiants
par exemple les l'inauguration de la
maison détruit en quelques télés
filiation est encore celui très grande
et longue interview celle ci qui est
vague qui est un bâtiment est un
instrument extrêmement intéressant les
étudiants ont investi il y a deux trois
choses comme ça le retour de notre
université au classement de shanghaï
rebonds mais aussi un rapport très très
récent de l'inspection générale de
l'enseignement supérieur qui mentionne
que notre université
dans ce qu'on appelle les petites et
moyennes universités est une des
meilleures en termes d'activités de
recherche je pense qu'il faut le
souligner je pense que c'est très
important ça témoigne de l'opiniâtreté
de nos collègues de l'ordre dynamisme de
leur persévérance et de leurs ambitions
voilà
et donc pour ce qui concerne 2016 et
bien je pense qu' il fallait souligner
ces éléments pour 2017
écoutez mon ambition sera de renforcer
la participation et l'existence de notre
université dans la construction de
paris-saclay enfin pour vraiment notre
retard dans cette construction est
d'essayer de poursuivre le développement
de quad et ses soeurs dans l'existant
dans tes de territoriale de notre
université de rendre compatibles notre
existence d'autres internationale avec
le terrain des étudiants qui sont la
seule université qu'il ya beaucoup
changé en 25 ans puisqu'elle célèbre
fête cette année son quart de siècle en
25 ans l'université a beaucoup changé
entre ce qui était prévu à l'origine est
ce qu'elle est devenue aujourd'hui elle
a su s'adapter aussi et évoluer avec la
société ce que j'ai je tiens j'en suis
sûr ce que j'ai pu lire de l'histoire
c'est qu'au départ cette université
avait été créé avec trois autres dans la
région ile-de-france pour j'ouvre les
guillemets désengorger paris
c'est un succès à l'université
versailles saint quentin en yvelines
parce que non seulement elle répond à
ces missions de formation avec deux
formations qui sont absolument
excellente mais en plus comme je les
subis et à l'oeuvre une recherche qui
est de tout premier plan
donc pour vous c'est un succès on peut
c'est un succès c'est à dire qu'on ne
peut pas malgré tout quand même oublier
les petits problèmes financiers qui ont
émaillé l'histoire de l'université
versailles saint quentin en yvelines ces
dernières années est ce que aujourd'hui
tout ça est oublié on pose régulièrement
la question mais en tout cas pour 2017
est ce que vous avez un peu plus de
marge de manoeuvre
non c'est pas oublié mais les finances
diversiterre sont extrêmement serrés le
budget qu'on a fait passer
était très difficile je suis arrivé aux
responsabilités au mois de mai dernier
j'ai bien vu que les choses étaient
compliquées que les collègues sont dans
des conditions qui sont pas optimales
aucun doute que les marges de manoeuvre
sont serrés j'espère que nous aurons des
marges de manoeuvre un peu plus élargie
durant l'année 2010 est si on n'a pas à
faire face à un nombre d'événements
inattendus de sécurité par exemple des
choses comme ça bon on est dans cette
situation là les seul et des finances
sont saines mais les marges de manoeuvre
sont extrêmement serrés
vous restez un plateau avec nous on va
continuer à parler d'éducation au sens
large on va parler et des métiers du btp
avec avec vous michel murr et directrice
du centre de formation aux métiers du
btp cet attrape
aujourd'hui on évoque une situation qui
non métiers du btp qui un regain
d'intérêt une situation qu'il irait un
petit peu mieux est ce que vous le
sentez vous vous le percevez tout à fait
aujourd'hui que ce soit dans le bâtiment
ou dans les travaux publics avec le
grand paris
des chantiers qui se sont ouverts
effectivement il ya une recrudescence en
termes d'apprentissage en tout cas de
demande
maintenant nous n'avons pas les
candidats à mettre en face donc nos
effectifs des débouchés avec des
salaires qu'il te fasse mais aujourd'hui
a pas forcément les cas bien tout est
rien c'est notre problème principal
aujourd'hui qu'est ce qui explique sa
connu alors oubliez désaffection pour
nos professions c'est clair pour le
bâtiment et les travaux publics même
pour les grands groupes pas que les
artisans les jeunes veulent faire des
sites long et c'est culturel je pense
c'est pas un problème qu'on peut
résoudre dans l'immédiat et nous en tant
que directeur opérationnel
nous sommes sans cesse obligés de
trouver de nouvelles solutions pour
satisfaire nos entreprises partenaires
notamment mon centre puisque nous sommes
purement patronale ne sont pas du tout
public nous sommes privés hors contrat
d'état
donc nous appartement la fédération du
bâtiment des travaux publics et de la
chambre syndicale nationale de
l'étanchéité donc est important pour
nous de trouver du personnel à nos entre
nos entreprises et comment vous faites
pour le prouver ce personnel
on essaie alors on fait de plus en plus
d'interventions dans les collèges et les
lycées c'est très difficile mais ça ne
suffit pas aujourd'hui on va chercher à
l'étranger
je vous le cache pas on est en train de
développer des filières en partie vers
la roumanie et le portugal ont laissé de
structurer pour essayer de faire
remonter dans les 200 250 jeunes lors de
votre témoignage par don est intéressant
parce qu'on parle toujours du chômage
qui progresse et de la difficulté de
faire baisser cette courbe du chômage et
on entend à côté qu'il existe des
métiers mais il ya personne n'a même
dans les fonctions c'est exactement ça
du niveau 5 au bts on a vraiment du mal
alors sur des bts on trouve des jeunes
on arrive à trouver des candidats mais
au niveau 50
on ne trouve pas et au niveau bac non
plus niveau 4 donc là vraiment il faut
qu'on en mette en place des solutions
aujourd'hui on travaille à beaucoup
avaient captivity également puisque nous
on a mis en place une
une formation expérimentale à
destination des bénéficiaires du rsa en
réduisant le temps de formation au
minimum c'est-à-dire à quatre mois alors
que ce type de public on in time est
généralement d'un dispositif de
formation de six arguments
donc là on réduit vraiment redonné de
l'attractivité pour avec les stages d'un
pouvoir permettre l'insertion
permettrait d'insertion en entreprise
mais c'est très compliqué des métiers
spécifiques sur lesquels aujourd'hui
vous n'avez pas de formation je pense à
cette formation vous lancez un d'agent
d'entretien débaptisation lasse et voilà
on le sait donner de la polyvalence pour
justement que les candidats recrutés
puisse aller un peu dans différents
métiers on essayait de pas les trous les
spécialisées de niveau 5
c'est pour donner aussi un diplôme à
quelqu'un bénéficiaires du rsa qui a
déjà une expérience dans le bâtiment qui
n'est pas valorisé qui a déjà des
connaissances à un certain niveau 1
niveau 5 donc c'est un petit niveau
malgré tout deux spécialités
voilà leur donner un diplôme qui leur
permettraient de saint céré concrètement
agent d'entretien des bâtiments ça
consiste en quoi cette formation
s'adresse à qui c'est le moment d'avoir
alors on a on a recruté bon voilà c'est
une formation qui démarrera le 27
février
elle est la section et complète
puisqu'on a fait un gros travail avec
pôle emploi
aujourd'hui on a une liste d'attentes ce
qui est très rare qui est très rare mais
on a fait un gros travail de sélection
et voilà l information c destinée à des
demandeurs d'emploi longue durée
bénéficiaires du rsa avec voilà notre
notre objectif final sur douze places si
d'insérer au minimum 90 % de ces
demandeurs d'emploi en entreprise on
parlait des évolutions pour l'université
avec les évolutions de la société les
évolutions économiques on aurait pu en
parler aussi des liens avec l'entreprise
en ce qui concerne vos professions vos
métiers il ya aussi une évolution des
métiers on parle de plus en plus de ces
normes de haute qualité environnementale
des choses comme ça on imagine que vous
avez su vous adapter et proposer des
formations en adéquation
alors oui on essaie de s'adapter nous on
va s'adapter surtout par rapport à la
formation à distance au numérique
obinna etc voilà tout c'est toutes ces
nouvelles informations toutes ces
nouvelles formations et surtout ses
modes
ces modes de formation qui sont
demandées par nos entreprises
même en alternance pour nos apprentis
donc nous on évolue vers ça il existe de
nombreux centres en ile de france qui
sont souvent concurrentiel et pourrait
volaille qui ont déjà des formations ne
va pas nous ouvrir des formations pour
faire concurrence à des collègues
alors qu'on a tous du mal je vous disais
tout à l'heure à remplir nos propres
formations
donc on reste est à même dans une
logique de développement de nos métiers
qui sont l'étanchéité les travaux
publics et on n'ira pas sur la conduite
d'un gène que mes collègues de tecomah
font déjà nous nous allons rester dans
notre champ de spécifier de spécialité
en tout cas il ya des postes à pourvoir
et des métiers pour lesquels être formés
on l'a bien compris dans votre centre de
formation merci d'être venu nous en
parler en plateau nous aurons l'occasion
d'y revenir parce que c'est intéressant
de voir qu'il existe des débouchés
aujourd'hui il y a de quoi peut-être pas
résorber le chômage mais en tout cas de
faire baisser un petit peu cette courbe
et puis merci est également didier du
mode est revenue en plateau on le
rappelle à l'université de versailles
saint quentin en yvelines qui fête ses
25 ans voilà vous y insérer les
témoignages d'anciens à l'intérieur
remarquable merci beaucoup à tous les
deux à ripley de cette édition sur notre
site internet
[Musique]